Чи можна говорити про успіх саміту в "нормандському" форматі в Парижі?
Досягнуті домовленості про обмін полоненими,
припинення вогню та подальше розведення сил - вкрай важливі,
проте з мертвої точки не вдалося зрушити найскладніші політичні питання:
про повернення Україні контролю над кордоном та місцеві вибори на Донбасі.
Позитивним більшість політологів, звісно, вважають те,
що довгоочікувана зустріч у "нормандському" форматі взагалі відбулася - вперше за три роки.
Нове українське керівництво ще з літа намагалося поновити перемовини "нормандської" четвірки.
А-от чи відбудеться і наступний саміт, поки не гарантує ніхто.
Це залежатиме від того, наскільки в наступні чотири місяці
будуть виконуватися ті цілі, про які учора говорили.
Обмін полоненими за принципом "усіх на усіх",
я переконаний, відбудеться, а ось щодо іншої цілі - тривалого припинення вогню - вже маю сумніви.
Якщо його не вдасться досягнути до кінця цього року, існує небезпека, що зустрічі не буде.
У такому разі одне з досягнень української сторони під час саміту в Парижі теж втратить сенс.
Адже Володимир Зеленський поставив у порядок денний усіх наступних переговорів
питання повернення контролю над кордоном на Донбасі.
А в перспективі це могло б призвести до оновлення "мінських угод",
поспіхом підписаних 2015 року заради негайного припинення бойових дій.
Наразі, всупереч побоюванням, відзначають оглядачі,
здачі українських інтересів під тиском російської сторони не сталося.
Як і раніше, існує єдина позиція щодо Росії,
а "червоні лінії", які проклала для себе Україна, не були перейдені.
І для Зеленського це є успіхом, зокрема з огляду на внутрішньополітичну ситуацію в Україні
та організовані певною частиною громадськості напередодні саміту протести проти нього.
Але у Парижі він не зрадив інтереси України,
а дотримувався дуже чіткої позиції і продемонстрував стійкість.
Однак у подальшому пошуки компромісу щодо найскладніших пунктів мінських угод
можуть звести нанівець успіхи саміту в Парижі.
Так, формальне повернення контролю над кордоном на Донбасі
ще не гарантуватиме відновлення суверенітету України.
Якщо взяти пропозицію Зеленського про те, що Україна перебирає
контроль за 36 годин до початку виборів,
це теж дуже небезпечно, тому що це буде малий проміжок часу.
І Росія може сказати "ну ок, в переддень виборів ви виходите на кордон".
А весь попередній час росіяни продовжують контролювати цю територію,
проросійські сили продовжують контролювати,
виборчу кампанію продовжують росіяни контролювати і так далі.
Те, що для досягнення миру необхідна політична воля не лише Києва,
а й Москви, усвідомлюють і в політичних колах Німеччини.
Ми бачимо чіткий сигнал того, що своїм пріоритетом президент Зеленський
бачить мир, але, вочевидь, все буде залежать від поведінки Росії.
Передбачений "Мінськом" режим припинення вогню можливий тільки за допомогою Москви.
Після переговорів у Парижі Росія залишається на своїх виграшних позиціях.
Як пише німецька преса, Володимира Путіна повністю влаштовує ситуація на Донбасі,
й поки не схоже, що він готовий до компромісів.
Наступна зустріч у "нормандському форматі"
має відбутися у квітні 2020 року - ймовірно, цього разу в Берліні.